un nuevo motín a miento se produjo en la
cárcel del tour en la ciudad de cuenca
al sur del país desde la madrugada de
este domingo hasta el momento el
ejecutivo nacional reveló 12 fallecidos
en el exterior de la cárcel sin conocer
las víctimas en el interior del centro
penitenciario la situación no está
controlada según las autoridades y las
cifras pudieran modificarse en un
informe previo detalló que 800
funcionarios de seguridad de distintas
ciudades son trasladados al centro
carcelario
55 personas fueron recapturadas por
intentos de fuga según la autoridad
oficial la cárcel de uno de los centros
penitenciarios más grandes del país que
a pesar de su magnitud mantiene
múltiples fallas de seguridad según un
informe de la asamblea nacional la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos también emitió recientemente un
informe de recomendaciones en el que
detalla fallas del sistema cárcel de
ecuador hace años altos niveles de
violencia y corrupción en todas las
casas del país abandono estatal el
sistema penitenciario ausencia de una
política de seguridad integral criminal
entre otras recomendaciones mientras que
un presidente informó en el parlamento
afirmó que la cárcel del tour y el
primer y segundo filtro de seguridad se
mantiene con falencias no funcionan
sensores de accesos scanner escáneres
corporales carne de vehículos y canes de
objetos las cámaras de los aviones no se
encuentran activas en ecuador ya se han
producido al menos cinco motín a mientos
en las cárceles desde el año 2020 hasta
la fecha